we're going to start off this hour with
Gabriel in Tampa Florida hi Gabriel how
are you I'm good how are you Dave better
than I deserve what's up yeah I just
wanted to let you know that I really
appreciate your program I went through
FPU and I loved it and I'm getting kind
of nervous because I had some some
family issues that happen in my life and
now I just need some encouragement
I have sixty seven thousand three
hundred thirty two dollars and 99 cents
in debt and I make sixty five thousand a
year I just wanted to know how much how
long it should take me to pay that off
well not counting family issues which
sometimes are known as a speed bump or
two or a rock or a rock wall in your way
or something like that I mean I just do
big math when I'm here on the air like
sixty seven thousand dollars in debt and
a 60 thousand dollar income is that what
you said
sixty-five see see five thousand dollar
income okay so if we pay some taxes and
we eat how many kids you got zero okay
and are you single yeah okay
so if you pay some taxes and you eat out
of sixty five thousand and let's just
say you put twenty two thousand dollars
towards the debt in three years that
would be sixty-six thousand dollars
and you would be debt free right yeah
yeah if you put thirty one thirty three
thousand dollars thirty four thousand
dollars towards the debt out of your
sixty five thousand you'd be debt-free
in two years right yeah
so that's how I do it I mean it's not
any more sophisticated than that when
I'm talking to somebody on the radio now
what you're gonna do is you're gonna sit
down with your actual budget on every
dollar and say if I live on beans and
rice rice and beans the good news is I
don't have a bunch of kids to feed and I
don't have a husband to control so all
I've got to just control me right and
some will control me yeah they're
dangerous you got no by griping at you
okay you know what countability built-in
but the good news is when you're single
you just got the person in the mirror
you
you know and so you just you just shut
down life and tell all your friends I'll
call you when I'm done or don't come
over and what do you think I should get
another job well the more money you make
the faster you get out right and the
faster you get out by the way the more
likely you are to get out and so I
really want you on a two-year plan for
your sake and you know gosh if you got
an extra job making $20,000 a year on
the weekends you'd be done in about 18
months or less right that's how I'm
doing there were some efforts go ahead
I'm sorry there were some opportunities
for me to move from where I am and
making an ID into an additional like ten
to fifteen thousand mm-hmm
what are your ties to all you are I mean
I kind of just started there haven't
been there for I haven't even been there
a year yet I left public accounting to
go to an opportunity and you know it's
not quite what I thought it was no no so
when you mean move you mean just change
companies you don't mean move physical
change company yeah yeah change
comfortable as long as it's not a bunch
of toxic jerks you're going to work for
a lousy 10 grand difference that'd be a
cool thing to do I mean maybe it's a
move up anyway regardless of the debt
right right yeah definitely extra 10 15
grand for the same job or a different
job or a better job that's moving you up
the ladder that's not a bad thing how
old are you 29 okay and what's the
family issue oh well I I was actually
engaged and we went there FPU together
mm-hm
and so we had a like a 20-month like 19
or 20 month plan to get out of that and
now it's like you know I really want to
you know still accomplish this goal but
you know it's kind of nerve-wracking to
do it on my own now though so the
engagement blew up yeah have anything to
do with money I know actually okay no
cool so on so you're free and it's just
you controlling you
you get after it and the more you work
the faster you're out but I would say
somewhere between 18 to 24 months you
ought to be done depending on how cheap
you live and how much extra work you do
okay that's the math you and I just did
together it didn't sound unreasonable to
me no it sounds perfectly reasonable the
good news is you're gonna be 31 years
old or you know 30 and a half or
something and debt-free and man what a
great place to be and you know at least
something good comes out of this
heartbreak of the broken engagement at
least you got Financial Peace University
and you got the knowledge and you can do
this right absolutely
you call me let me know how you're doing
okay okay thank you so much I think you
can do it I do too